each peasant today we present the newest
member of BMWs ex family from the front
it strongly echos the x3 and guess what
the technology is based on the x3 as
well but from the back it's a coupe a
like the BMW x6 and price and features
though it's more like an x5 so
the BMW x4 isn't really an SUV but as a
sea or sports activity coupe a let's see
what I can do his forerunner the x6
caused a stir when it appeared many
thought it looked too massive but the
car sold well its concept has now been
adapted for the smaller x4 together with
the grand coupe a it completes the
carmaker's 4 series it's aimed at SUV
drivers who want to stand out from the
crowd
BMW's Richard Jacobi says it's a car for
SUV drivers in the premium mid-range
class who are looking for a special
performance and unique design on the
outside the x4 is brawny and confident
from the side that recalls the
silhouette of the x6 there's a new
double creasing over the rear-wheel
cargo space ranges from 500 to 1400
liters inside like all 4 Series models
its high-quality and elegant while still
offering a touch of sportiness the rear
bench is spacious enough for longer
trips in fact the x4 is designed as a 2
plus 1 seen a bit tight for the one in
the middle but behind the driver Sacha
has enough space for his knees and more
importantly despite the coop a roof
enough Headroom - but in Reverse the
coop a shape does cause problems looking
through the back window you see
practically nothing but the car offers
two possibilities in Reverse there's the
360 degree overhead view or a rear view
camera an all-school the basic version
with the engine we tested can be have
458 thousand euros in Germany but our
model had every available extra feature
raising the price to a lofty 78 thousand
euros
takes fuse Richard Jacobi says the
x-force technology is based on the x3
but it puts a greater emphasis on
performance and design it's a lifestyle
car a new take on BMWs familiar x6
concept don't miss become conceptus
austin VMV x6 together with its siblings
the x3 x5 and x6
the x4 is built in BMW Spartanburg South
Carolina plant North America is one of
its main sales markets with global
demand for the EX models undiminished
BMW is investing a billion dollars in
the facility within two years annual
production capacity will expand by 50%
from 300,000 units to 450,000 about 70
percent of the cars built here are
exported throughout the globe decisively
Richard Jacoby explains the price
difference between the x3 and x4 the x4
has much more generous standard features
basically all the x3
optional sports and performance features
are standard on the x4 features full mix
Daiya a mix fear celia likes performance
control sports steering link sports
leather steering wheel with paddles and
sports automatic transmission the x4
also has rear assistance parking an
automatic rear hatch standard and in
most markets Centon headlights and
18-inch wheels the x4 is just as happy
on trails and unpaved roads as on the
highway as the same off-road specs as
the x3 BMW sees its customers mainly in
the US and China but Germany and Italy
have enough interested buyers to
for design but in Sasha's opinion the x4
is too classy for those kinds of
surfaces and at seventy eight thousand
euros it's also quite expensive
visibility and back is limited but the
car is a real looker